Adam Dwayne the rock roommate in man not
expecting anybody
it's move-in day Wow okay pointing
fingers already not a good start to our
relationship hope you don't mind already
kind of laid claim to this squadron
that's that's great because I've got the
the microwave and I'll just put it there
so sick mark I love popcorn so hey
greetings earthlings honors hold Vic
Resident Advisor hi I'm Blake
wait sup i'm adam demamp you play sports
swim team so no oh yeah that's funny you
know it's not funny burning alive in the
middle of the night because you don't
know your microwave just caught on fire
microwaves not allowed in the dorms so
I'll be taking this because I'm your RA
hey no I didn't mean all that come on
man just give me a break there are no
break how college Oh cut it out pull
those up no I'm sorry I I was so close
to finishing when you came in initially
you're lucky I don't write you up all
right you two are on my Sgt list and
it's a short list it's too long T oh wow
welcome to college babe
greetings earthlings momma's home day
you